automatikuhren für viele menschen der
inbegriff von handwerkskunst auf
höchstem niveau einen rein mechanisch
funktionierendes system das keine
batterien oder elektro braucht um über
jahrzehnte oder sogar jahrhunderte
unglaublich präzise zu funktionieren mit
dem immer größer werdenden hype um
solche luxus uhren und speziell
diamantbesetzte luxusuhren kam mir immer
mehr fragen wie entstehen die haben wo
kauft man diese und welche schritte sind
erforderlich um eine scheinbar fertige
nur mit diamanten zugesetzt viel spaß
mit diesem blick hinter die kulissen von
eis taut luxusuhren reise beginnt für
mich und die uhr in diesem falle eine
katia santos von justin in köln
ziel der reise soll zürich sein wo ich
mich mit disco und deren partner treffe
die schweiz geld wie allgemein bekannt
als absolutes uhren mekka marken wie
rolex oder makeba oder patek philippe
kommen aus der schweiz und produzieren
dort auch nach wie vor als erstes
spreche ich mit einem sehr erfahrenen
diamantenhändler welcher jiechi und co
und einschlägige schweizer
uhrenmanufakturen beliefert mein name
ist mir auch selber tätig für die
schweizer uhrenindustrie und meine
aufgaben sind da eigentlich diamanten zu
organisieren die die uhrenindustrie
verwenden kann auf der einen seite und
das material ganz normal brillanten und
auf der anderen seite jegliche fantasie
sachen karneval und und aus der dazu
geld machen können und ich probiere
allgemeinen überblick zu schaffen ganz
grob was bedeutet wie die etwas bedeutet
wie es oder wie werden einheiten
angegeben und was bedeutet das ganze
eigentlich ganz gut
richtig ist eine kurze abwanderung man
hat ja irgendwann mal eine lösung
gesucht um die diamanten preislich zu
gratulieren und eine einstellung zu
finden und hat dann aufgrund der
reinheit das in die wege geleitet da
gibt es nur englische begriffe das heißt
das fängt an bei gf gs wie es das wunder
sind diese begriffe
das heißt zum beispiel weil diesmal
inklusions für fahrlässig was man mit
einer zehnfach lupe diamanten werden
heute noch gratuliert und auch preislich
fixiert mit einer zehnfach lupe oder
besser und war mit einem mikroskop auch
in der zehnfache einstellung und auch
das was man da man sagt dass eingeübt
und diamant prüfer sieht wird
zertifiziert und gibt es vorgaben wenn
so viele anschlüsse sind oder die um die
spezielle ort dann fällt mir interesse
oder es viel viel mehr in vsf ich
eigentlich die beste variante die es
gibt
das ist dann komplett ohne einschlüsse
ohne beschädigungen ohne luft blasen
oder irgend etwas noch gibt wäre flowers
kennt man aber beim klein premium
bereich gar nicht dass ich dann auch von
der macher vom schlafenden
proportionales absolutes top material
also wird nach wie vor wirklich mit auge
eingestuft in welche kategorie
7 ja man kann auch etwa weil es sicher
es gibt gewisse dass ich das problem was
man hat beim geschliffenen diamanten die
reflektionen von den verschiedenen
facetten dass man eben halt gewisse ein
schlüsselthema doppelt und dreifach sieg
und der mensch in der lage ist das raus
zu selektionieren das gibt es nur einmal
sich da hinten darum reflektiert oder
eben nicht es gibt mittlerweile für den
industriebereich versuche das man
fototechnik versucht die sachen zu
gratulieren
das aber auf einem sehr bescheidenen
leben und alles was schon contor
industries werde nach wie vor komplett
von hand gemacht okay was natürlich
nicht außer acht gelassen werden darf
ist das ganze thema der farbe es klingt
für einen außenstehenden immer ein
bisschen speziell das sind weiße
diamanten das spreche da bitteschön von
farbe es geht darum dass der diamant
das was wir im schmuckbereich nur im
bereich betrafen in einer gelb linie
eigentlich sich aufbaut und je weniger
geld ein teil der stein hat umso besser
ist das beste was man kennt ist die
video war
wenn sie mich fragen warum fängt an bei
dea hat historische gründe
die leute haben sehr früh festgestellt
irgendwie muss und dass zeugen mal
einordnen und irgendwie muss man eine
lösung suchen
und dann hat hama gegeben und auch 1 und
b und c und ich weiß nicht was alles und
diversen drei vier fünf buchstaben waren
besetzt und das ist das game logical in
city und auf amerika als weltweit nach
wie vor das einzige nicht industrie
geförderte unternehmen gibt eigentlich
die marschrichtung vor
und die waren damals in den tunnelwelten
frühen 20er jahren die ersten die gesagt
werden müssen einfach skala erarbeiten
und weil eben arbeite arbeite schon
besetzt wobei die gestartet es gilt dann
runter ist bisschen schlechter fg htc
wir hier in europa vorwiegend auch in
der schweiz wir verarbeiten eigentlich
nie schlechter als h
das hat einen ganz ganz ganz deutschland
für einen gelb ton den man nur sieht
wenn man so genannte referenz steine hat
und dann eben die anderen hinlegt um zu
sehen ob ich ein bisschen geldbörse ein
bisschen weniger zb usa arbeitet er
gerne auch mit
ihr und und grabsteinen die haben zum
ganz das schon ein bisschen sichtbaren
geld wurde an die amerikaner das auch
ein bisschen propagieren im sinne des
looks like a candle light
das hat mir so ein bisschen emotion und
ist hübsch ist natürlich ein unterschied
das heißt die top kosten und die sind im
absoluten luxussegment zu hause und ge
ist eigentlich das was der juwelier bei
uns in der regel verarbeitet und dann
hauen und weiter und sind die preiswert
uns auch bei weitem nicht schlecht
möchte das ganz klar sagen aber einfach
vergessen haben dass sobald man sich
dann für diamanten in der gewünschten
reinheit um farbe entschieden hat geht
es für die uhr und die steine zum
besetzen will ihn noch ganz kurz darauf
hinweisen dass alle interviews und extra
content in voller länge für kanal
mitglieder zur verfügung steht außerdem
hat das video extrem viel geld gekostet
wenn ihr mich also unterstützen wollt
und lust auf extra content habt dann
schließt gerne einen kanal
mitgliedschaft ab
die wieder zu
[Musik]
nachdem die uhr dann wirklich mit
unglaublicher präzision besetzt und
wieder zusammengebaut wurde ging es für
mich und die uhr zurück nach köln zur
auslieferung
entschieden hast und wie der ganze
prozess natürlich war ja klar
also wir haben hier ein kartenhaus ins
eis m
also gibt es ein m und xl ich glaube das
sind 38 und 41 millimeter war nach
seinem 37
ja und ich habe mich dazu entschieden
diese zu besetzen
die biz mit weißem platz die xl gibt es
mit weißen blauen dach und ich finde das
eigentlich ganz meist ja des weiteren
arbeitet natürlich wie das vielleicht
schon mit mitchell zusammen und deswegen
habe ich mich da gar nicht lange gefragt
war wenig umsetzen lasse ja ich wollte
heute als alternative zu der auch sagen
was in flames ziffernblatt hat die jungs
meinten dass es sehr gut hinbekommen ich
bin mehr als überrascht also ist
wirklich krass gewonnen und das ist eine
uhr die halt einmal dadurch das
ziffernblatt playlist etwas schlechter
ist aber auch dadurch dass die was
kleiner ist ich kann das jetzt mal so
als vergleich daneben müssen
man sieht halt deutlich dass die
bisschen größer ist als die partie sich
aber noch selbst bin noch mal zufrieden
mit der burg karte liefert sehr leicht
der mensch war
ja danke nicht nur schwer zu sehen was
da so richtig und was man noch so lernen
können über diamonds ja ein sehr anderes
video geht zu ende ich hoffe ihr hattet
beim zu sehen genauso viel spaß wie ich
beim produzieren
es war sehr aufwändig ich würde mich
über ein like oder eure meinung in den
kommentaren freuen
vergesst nicht zu abonnieren damit ihr
kein video mehr verpasst das nächste
video wird wieder so wie die anderen
videos und jeglichen rahmen sprengen
macht's gut